hey 42 here automata are machines
capable of carrying out actions
according to a predetermined set of
instructions
they are not new inventions with
examples cropping got back in ancient
greece and
china cesibius for example who is
thought to have been the first head of
the great library of alexandria
is known to have invented several
water-based automata
as early as 200 bc but in 1770
wolfgang von kemphelen unveiled an
automaton
the likes of which the world has never
seen before
at the time most automata were nothing
more than fairground attractions
elaborate illusions built with
mechanical wizardry and
designed to look impressive and lifelike
but von keppelin's machine was different
why because it could play chess
from a purely technical standpoint the
mechanical turk
as von kemp helen's automaton was known
was impressive able to select any chess
piece on the board at will
and execute its move perfectly but
it wasn't mere technical mastery that
sent
shockwaves across europe when the turk
was first unveiled
because whilst playing a game of chess
is simply a case of moving the pieces
from place to place
something any cleverly designed
automaton at the time might have
achieved
winning a game of chess is another
matter entirely
that requires genuine human intelligence
and yet the mechanical turk a mere
machine by all
accounts almost always
one in our world of smartphones and
computers
it's hard to imagine just how much of a
stir the mechanical turk could have
caused in its day
we're surrounded by machines that can
think or at least
appear to think on a day-to-day basis
but in 1770 the world looked very
different
we were still lighting our homes with
fire for a start
the light bulb wouldn't be invented for
over a hundred years back then
concepts that are so familiar to us
today like ai
and machine learning hadn't even made it
into the pages of science fiction novels
that's partly because science fiction
novels hadn't even been invented yet
of course mary shelley's frankenstein
generally considered to be the first
science fiction novel
would not be published for almost 50
years when the mechanical turk advanced
its very first
porn in 1770. like
many of the world's best inventions
wolfgang von kemp
helen developed the mechanical turk to
impress a girl and not just any girl the
queen of hungary
and bulgaria and archduchess of austria
marry teresa to be exact regular viewers
will be delighted to hear that maria
happens to be the only female sovereign
of the house of habsburg
my word those chin wielding royals
certainly got around
although i am a little sorry to report
that maria theresa
seems to have escaped the signature
sledgehammer chin
of her kinsman perhaps feeling a little
left out at her facial inadequacies
in later life she did try and make up
for it by cultivating
a fairly impressive double chin instead
got to make the parents proud eh
the mechanical turk was a life-sized man
carved out of wood
that sat before a large cabinet on which
rested a chessboard
when von kemp helen first revealed the
automaton to maria theresa
at chambrun palace he started by giving
the queen a guided tour of the inner
workings of the machine
something that would become his custom
at the start of an exhibition
one by one he would open a series of
doors in the cabinet
shining a candle within to reveal a maze
of
cogs springs and gears having shown his
audience there was no monkey business
going on inside the cabinet
von ken pelin then asked for a
challenger to step
forward to play the turk the man who did
so
was ludwig von kombenzel plenty
potentiary minister to the queen
and for all you conspiracy theory lovers
out there
known member of the illuminati
unfortunately
his chess game didn't exhibit too much
enlightenment
and to the general astonishment of
everyone present
he was dispatched by the turk in under
30 minutes
several other challengers came forward
that day and
the turk trounced every single
one of them word of the incredible chess
playing automaton spread across
europe like wildfire but to everyone's
surprise
von kemp pelham became strangely coy
about exhibiting his machine
often making obscure claims about the
need for repairs to
avoid taking on challenges over the
course of the next 10 years
the turk faced just one more opponent
and
after the match kemp helen dismantled
the turk
for good or at least he would have done
had maria theresa's son
holy roman emperor joseph ii not
ordered him to rebuild his autobiton for
the state visit
of the grand duke paul of russia
reluctantly
von kemphelen did so and the event
was another resounding success such a
success in fact
that von kempelen agreed to take the
turk
on a tour of europe the first stop was
france
where the turk was displayed to the
public for the very first time
during their stay in paris ron kemp
helen and the mechanical turk
took on all comers including a chess
loving american by the name
of benjamin franklin he was working as
ambassador to france for the united
states at the time
the turk put the future founding father
to the sword
having said that whilst your automaton
did win more than its fair share of
games
against the toughest opponents around it
was occasionally bested
including by francois andre danikan
philidor
considered to have been easily the
strongest chess player of his day
though even he claimed to have been
given one of the toughest games of his
life
the following years saw the turk
exhibited in cities across europe
before returning to its original home at
the schonbrunn palace
where it was to stay until von
kemphelen's death in 1804
the following year von kenpelin's son
sold the machine
to a man named johann nepomuk malzel for
ten
thousand francs it's fair to say that
malzel was something of a character
during his time as owner of the turk he
would make friends with ludwig von
beethoven
convincing the composer to write a piece
of music for him called
the battle of victoria but beethoven
would later claim
marzel had defrauded him by stealing the
score
and passing it off as his own going so
far
as to call him a rude churlish man
entirely devoid of education or
cultivation
malzel also found time to take credit
for the invention of the metronome which
he patented
despite the fact that dietrich nicholas
winkle
was the true inventor marzelle is often
erroneously credited with the invention
to this day don't you just hate it when
you invent a gravity-based timekeeping
device and get ripped off
perhaps unsurprisingly considering what
we know about him
marzel's interest in the mechanical turk
was largely
financial he even managed to sell the
automaton for three times what he paid
for it at one
point though he bought it back again not
long after
malzel did manage to make improvements
to the turk though
including adding a voice box that
allowed it to declare czech
in french when attacking its opponent's
king
to begin with malzel only puts on
exhibitions rarely
but every once in a while someone will
come along looking for a game who he
simply couldn't refuse one such opponent
was none other than napoleon bonaparte
as we all know napoleon was a military
general of rare genius
a quick thinker capable of turning any
situation to his advantage
that might be why he kicked off his game
against a turk
by breaking one of malzel's golden rules
napoleon tried to play as white
meaning he took the first move napoleon
probably expected marzel to step
in but it was the turk himself who was
having none of the general shenanigans
the automaton shook its wooden head then
removed the erroneous piece from the
board entirely
napoleon nothing if not persistent tried
the trick again
and then a third time at which point his
mechanical adversary
apparently lost its temper sweeping its
arm across the board
and scattering the pieces to the floor
napoleon had probably had men guillotine
for less
but he seemed to like a bit of spunk
when it came to automata
to malzel's relief the general found the
turks antics hilarious
napoleon replaced the pieces on the
board himself
allowed the turk to play white as was
its custom
and settled in for chess-based war
just 19 moves later outmaneuvered
and outgunned napoleon bonaparte was
beaten
whilst people were understandably
intrigued and astonished by the
mechanical turk
many were also more than a little
perturbed
you see its invention by von kemp helen
came hot on the heels of the dawn of the
industrial revolution
for the first time in human history
people were beginning to fear that
machines might start to replace them
in the workplace it was happening right
before their eyes after all
and if one of these machines could truly
think for itself
well the implications were frightening
we see these very same fears today with
the right of automation
robotics and ai a machine capable of
logical thought
was an outlandish idea but while some
people were
afraid of the consequences others were
simply struck by the possibilities
a man named charles babbage played the
mechanical turk
twice in 1819 losing soundly on both
occasions
despite the losses or perhaps because of
them
the idea of a thinking machine lodged
itself
indelibly in babbage's mind because
as you'll have learned if you watched my
video on quantum computing
charles babbage is credited with having
drawn up the designs
for the very first computer the
analytical engine
and he began work on a precursor to that
machine the difference engine just two
years
after losing to the turk so some people
were afraid
and others inspired but there was
another common reaction people had to
the turk
when faced with a machine that could
think for itself
they called [ __ ] in 1826
malzel took the turk to america opening
an exhibition in new york that drew
people in from all over the country
amongst them was a young edgar allan poe
known today as a titan of american
literature but
at the time just another reporter for
the southern literary messenger
poe was absolutely convinced the turk
was a fake
an elaborate hoax that concealed a
simple truth
the intelligence behind the turk's chess
was not mechanical at
all but human he set about trying to
prove his thesis with the doggedness of
a detective
tracking those involved with the turk
and watched it play on several occasions
his efforts are thought to have inspired
him to create
c august dupont a fictional detective
who appeared in his story
the murders in the room morgue the first
ever
locked room mystery dupont incidentally
a remarkable detective who was helped by
his
unremarkable assistant to solve
seemingly impossible crimes
is thought to have at least partly
inspired the creation of
you guessed it sherlock holmes poe's
investigations
soon bore fruit because in his
observations of the turks exhibitions
he had seen something strange or more
specifically
someone strange poe had noticed a man
william schlumberger assisting in the
setup and dismantling of the turk
scrumburger was of medium build with a
pronounced stoop
and whilst poe always saw him before and
after the turks games
he never once saw him during them
even more interesting poe discovered
that when schlumberger fell ill one day
before the turk was due to play
the game was mysteriously cancelled at
short notice
had poe known one other key piece of
information about schlumberger
it would have been an open and short
case
because malzel's elusive assistant just
so happened to be
a european chess master poe attempted to
uncover the ruse when he published his
findings in a popular essay
titled malzel's chess player and while
some of his assumptions in the piece
were
dead wrong he believed sclumburger
concealed himself within the body of the
turk for example
poe was in general dead right
the turk was not the world's first ai
it was an illusion a magic trick
an 84 year old hoax that had taken in
some of the world's most powerful people
and plenty of others besides the real
genius of the turk
wasn't that it could actually play chess
it was that it was convincing enough
to fool so many people for so long
remember how wolfgang von kenpelin would
open the doors to the toast cabinet
one by one shining a candle on the inner
workings
it certainly looked convincing but it
was this consecutive opening of the
doors
that allowed the trick to work the
complicated machinery ronkenpellin had
stuffed inside
was nothing but a smoke screen and for
that matter
an actual screen there to both distract
the viewer
and conceal the chess player behind
the cogs and gears which did nothing
more than make a racquet by the way
didn't actually extend all the way
through to the back of the cabinet
leaving a cavity behind just big enough
to house a sliding seat that allowed the
chess player within
to slip out of sight as the cabinet
doors
opened and closed once the cabinet was
shut
and the game ready to begin the hidden
player would light a candle
the smoke from which escaped from a tube
which exited
out of the turks turbine and would get
ready to play the game
a series of magnets built into the
chessboard allowed him to see which
moves were being made
and he was able to make his own moves in
response
using a device called a pantograph which
mirrored his own hand movements on the
board above
an illusion it may have been but
it was an incredibly effective one
incidentally
william schlungberger wasn't the first
chess player to operate the turk
and he wouldn't be the last it isn't
known who took on the role in von kemp
helen's time
but malzell used several chess players
from all over europe
and it's no wonder the turk rarely lost
all were strong players one william
lewis
is thought to have been the first player
in history to have been called
a grand master aside from their playing
strength
all of marselle's chess players shared
one thing in common
they were strapped for cash which is
exactly what malzahl used to convince
them to play for him
though a few did manage to get their own
back by blackmailing him mercilessly on
the threat
of revealing his big secret
unsurprisingly
malzer left the states not long after
poe's essay was published
taking the turk to cuba but schlumberger
contracted yellow fever during the trip
and died taking the turk's chess ability
with him to the grave
without a skilled player to operate his
automaton
malzel headed back to the u.s depressed
and like many depressed men he turned to
drink
it was to be the death of him he died
from alcohol poisoning during the voyage
the turk changed hands a couple of times
in the years after
eventually being bought by edgar allan
poe's personal physician
john cursely mitchell who donated it to
the peel museum in baltimore
where it would remain largely forgotten
until
a fire broke out in the museum in 1854.
mitchell arrived on the scene just in
time to watch the turk
burn unable to intervene due to the
ferocious heat
he claims to have been able to hear the
automaton's last
desperate words above the roaring flames
check check check check
check well that's going to give me
nightmares
with the automaton destroyed mitchell's
son
silly ass decided it was high time to
finally come clean
he published a series of essays in chess
weekly that explained exactly how the
turk
had fooled the world no longer afoot
the game was simply up
the amazing chess playing automaton had
gained great renown in its 84 years
playing in royal courts going to war
with generals
taking on some of the greatest chess
minds of its time
and inspiring inventions that changed
the world
its story which pitted a cold machine
intelligence
against the best mankind had to offer
captured imaginations around the world
in a way that wouldn't be seen again
until
gary kasparov took on ibm supercomputer
deep blue in 1996.
kasparov was the victor in that one but
ibm and deep blue
were back the following year and this
time they took
kasparov down but in an interesting
parallel to the mechanical turks own
story
there were those present who smelt a rat
and since edgar allan poe was long dead
by this point
it was left to kasparov himself to call
[ __ ]
for most of game one deep blue had been
making the kind of moves kasparov
expected of a computer
logical calculating predictable
but then in the end game the
supercomputer made a move that shocked
the world chess champion
to his marrow not because of its
strength per se but because of its
imagination
to kasparov it didn't seem like a
computer move
at all and he became convinced that
just like the mechanical turk deep blue
was being helped out
by a human mind or in this case
a team of chess grandmasters working in
tandem
to thwart him it was a conspiracy
theorist's wet
dream not least because ibm delayed the
release of their computer
logs for some time after the match and
even went as far to dismantle deep blue
after its victory reminding anyone of a
certain wolfgang von kenpellin
dismantling the turk after his
performance at the sean broome palace by
any chance
and if you're looking for a motive here
look no further
ibm's share price is said to have risen
by some 20
in the aftermath of the victory as it
happens kasparov was right
when he said the stunning human-like
move from game one
was not the product of honouring machine
logic
but it wasn't the work of a team of
chess grand masters either so what was
it
a bug in deep blues programming actually
which had prevented the computer from
playing its preferred move
to overcome the error a fail-safe mode
had kicked in
in which the supercomputer deep blue
simply played a move
at random unlike the mechanical turk
whose opponents thought they were
playing a machine but were really
playing a man
kasparov thought he was playing a man
when in fact
he was really playing a machine still
these days chess computers are light
years ahead of the world's best players
and us non-grand masters are likely to
be trounced
every time by a simple smartphone
application
there's no getting around it the times
when an old chess
master hidden in a cabinet behind a big
wooden doll
could take the world by storm are well
and truly over
mostly pity if you ask me thank you for
watching
you can now pre-order my new book
sticker flagging it on amazon
link in the description thank you